let's bring in now retired air force
general richard myers former chairman of
the joint chiefs of staff under
president george w bush general myers
thanks for being here
you bet hard to believe 20 years you
know back then uh you had another three
weeks before you were permanently going
to be the chairman of the joint chiefs
talk to me about the reflections of 9 11
that day
well i was acting chairman that day as i
think you know and
it was a day that's
imprinted on my memory will never leave
of course
the visuals of people
leaping out of the world trade centers
to save themselves
uh the carnage the loved ones
lost and the loved ones left behind uh
the heroic acts by first responders
uh fire police medical
and of course uh the members on uh the
group the the pastors on flight 93 that
crashed in pennsylvania so that's i
think a lot about that i also think
about how unified this country was
uh
right after 9 11 driving around
washington dc and seeing cars with
american flags
uh streaming out of them all over the
city uh by everybody uh we were we were
very
cohesive in that day in our in our
thoughts and
and our wishes for
you know dealing with al qaeda i can
remember the visits to congress a lot of
solidarity there as well of course 20
years a lot has changed for a lot of
reasons
but uh i kind of long for that
solidarity that that 911 brought to the
united states of america you wish you
had done something different after 9 11
you've had kind of two decades to look
back
and uh from your perspective your
vantage point
yeah so for my my perch i think the one
thing that frustrated me the longer i
was
in office and of course i left in 2005
but
was the inability of the united states
to bring all our
instruments of national power
to bear on the problem
so uh
i think we overused a military
instrument and i mean just calling it a
war on terror if it's a war that must
mean the military right but it was more
than that uh it was competition a battle
of ideas
uh
competition inside the uh
islam to figure their way to deal with
modernity and these are issues uh left
to the economic
uh instruments of power informational
political
um diplomatic and i don't think those
were brought to bear in the way they
they should have been
uh to to help with the military peace
which the military is going to play a
piece of this of course a big role but
but they can't do it alone and i that's
one of the things that is
that has frustrated me that we could
never kind of get that getting traction
on those kind of ideas i wanted to play
a sound by back from the press
conference where we just initiated
military action inside afghanistan take
a listen
today our forces have begun the initial
part
of military operations in the war
against terrorism visible or not
our friends and enemies should
understand that all instruments of our
national power
as well as those of our friends and
allies around the world
are being brought to bear on this global
menace innocent lives are still at risk
today and will be
until we have dealt with the terrorists
if there were an easy
safe way to route terrorist networks
out of countries that are harboring them
it would be a blessing
but there is not
now it's interesting to look back at the
start of that and today general the the
taliban that you called a terror group
now
is in control of afghanistan just get
your thoughts on how things have gone
over the last couple of weeks and what
you've seen
well it's
i mean for for those of us that
we're on the front end of this uh that
saw the the hope
and the eyes and thoughts and
conversations we had with our afghan
friends
uh to have that all
dashed or at least
most of it dashed at this point
is is just
just so sad
and
you know of course the way it all ended
was a little bit
chaotic a lot chaotic it would have been
nice if it could have been more orderly
but
i'm
i don't have any inside information i
don't know about all the planning that
went behind all that it was just kind of
sad to see it
come out like that and then um since
we've been so involved in afghan
charities and so forth since
uh my 10 years particularly my wife mary
jo
lots of calls for help to get us on list
that would get
people that felt they were at risk or
their families were at risk to get them
out of afghanistan and it's just
heartbreaking i mean
you know 20 years
a lot of people have been educated a lot
of women have been educated in those 20
years thousands of people have had
a
a better education than they ever had
hoped for under the tata bomb before him
and so where that where is that going to
go
i don't think any of us know at this
point we'll see if this taliban is a new
and better taliban i think a lot of us
have our doubts but we're hopeful too
that
uh maybe they'll maybe they'll be
different this time around which is
enough different to give everybody a
chance yeah we just heard from lucas
thomason down at guantanamo bay
why do you think there hasn't been a
trial for the 911 mastermind we're at 20
years here and we're pre-trial
hearings
yeah i think
you know it's it's well documented that
uh
several presidents have tried really
hard to close it down and expedite these
trials and the complexities of the
issues involved
uh are such i guess that they just can't
get it done i do not know the
intricacies anymore uh when i was on
active duty we were not quite to the
trial stage when i was still in service
and i so i haven't fought it closely
enough to know that the legal
complexities of why this isn't happening
but it's um it's not it's clearly not
good it's not good for the us image
um as bad as these people are they need
a trial that's one of the things that we
guarantee our citizens i know they're
not our citizens but uh the right thing
to do is get on with the trial and let
justice take its course two more things
should the military be held accountable
for
let's say happy talk about the status of
afghan national forces considering what
we saw
uh in recent days
is the media involved in that should we
have been asking tougher questions to
you all
you know that's a great that's a great
question and i'm i
those were the same questions we had
when i was chairman as we're starting to
train people and how many resources have
you put to training afghan forces and so
forth can they
can they be
an effective force in the end it it
turned out they weren't but
i think what they rely on a lot
as the country was trying to become a
country and not a
a tribal a group of tribes
i think they relied heavily on u.s
advisers to
to focus them
and to to be the informal leaders and
the inspiration for what they were doing
and without that then it falls apart
pretty quickly and i'm also told there
was a lot of corruption in the hierarchy
in the afghan army so
uh the high ranking officers were maybe
not always paying the lower ranking
officers which doesn't build a lot of
loyalty obviously so there's
i think there were a lot of issues with
that and i think we all should have been
asking a lot of questions i you know i
obviously i haven't been in
many briefing rooms where that was
discussed so i i can't give you the
specifics on
last thing it's a it's a heavy one for
the last one in retrospect in 20 years
looking back do you think going into
iraq was a mistake and
drained resources and attention from
afghanistan
yeah i don't
personally i i don't think that was
as big an issue as people like to make
it certainly
those are two big operations they do
take i mean it's the intellectual
uh capital and the energy you have to
deal with with problems
but
you know i think we we could handle that
things ebbed and flowed right so
afghanistan at one point was looking
pretty good then it got worse and it got
a little bit better and
i remember telling a reporter in
afghanistan one of my first visits that
if we're going to be successful in
afghanistan
the afghan people are going to need
several generations
to change
if they want to change for for the
better
and uh
we just
you know we never we never got there but
i'm not sure i would i would say that we
didn't have the resources to do both
although when you consider all
instruments of national power
um you know we made both of those
problems
uh heavily a military problem and i
think that's
that that wasn't correct
joel myers we really appreciate your
time on this day i enjoyed listening to
you at
secretary rumsfeld's funeral and the
words you said about working alongside
him
and uh we appreciate your remembrances
today
i hope everybody remembers this was uh
tomorrow is an important commemoration
of
surprise which was bad we don't want to
be surprised again
and uh
and a glimpse into what just a handful
of people
that are
wanting to hurt innocent men women and
children can do when they're properly
motivated that that threat's still out
there and i think we need to remain
vigilant and and uh people should work
very hard so we aren't surprised again
thank you sir
thank you brad hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else